Привет, молодёжь. Это Михаил Гребенюк. И
в ближайшие 30 минут я постараюсь вас
удивить фактами, которые помогут вам
преуспеть в жизни в следующие 10-15 лет.
Этот эфир, этот видеозапись особенно
актуально всем посмотреть, кто кому
сейчас 15, 16, 18 и 20 лет, потому что я
виртуально попытался стать успешным,
оказаться в вашем возрасте и виртуально
попытаться стать успешным в будущем в
следующие 15 лет. И вот что у меня
получилось. Об этом я расскажу,
собственно, в этой презентации, в этом
своей небольшой лекции. Это наш марафон
от проекта поколения, нашего богатырного
проекта "Кем быть". Итак, представим
себе, что сегодня мне 33 года, но
представим себе так, что я ваш ровесник,
но я немножко больше уже понимаю то, что
полетал о том, как устроен мир, как
устроен бизнес, как устроена карьера, и
постараюсь поделиться, какие же лайфхаки
могут помочь нам преуспеть. А проблема в
том, значит, первый тезис, с который
хочется начать, что что я понял про
жизнь. К сожалению, судьба и наша жизнь
- это не точная наука. Есть такая наука,
как алгебра, ну или математика, там
геометрия, физика, химия. Это достаточно
точные науки. Ну, например, там вот
водород. Хты тресни. У водорода будет
один атом, правильно? Он не будет два
атома. Он что миллиард лет назад был
один атом, через миллиард лет у водорода
тоже будет один атом. Это точное
показатели, которые измеряются для всей
вселенной одинаково. Или возьмём
скорость света. Это достаточно точная,
понятная единица измерения, которая
одинаковая для, что нашей галактики, что
для другой галактики. Но, к сожалению,
планирование жизни - это наука неточная.
Это такая же наука, как риторика для
меня, как
бизнес, предпринимательство,
планирование там, да, вот как психология
где-то, где медицина, где-то, да, где
вот мы пытаемся предугадать. И вот я
предлагаю нам посмотреть на ваше с вами
будущее из позиции того, что мы не
знаем, мы не можем точно быть уверены,
что будет завтра. Как же тогда
поступать, как планировать своё будущее,
если ты не знаешь, что будет завтра. А я
хочу привести пример. Вот представьте
себе, что мы с вами оказались
в такой цели, что нам нужно построить
абсолютно новый спортивный автомобиль.
Вот, может, вы знаете историю. Был такой
Enzo Ferrari, который был основателем
марки Ferrari. Он построил шикарную
машину. И в Италии после времён Второй
мировой войны вернулся механик, который
собрал первый небольшой трактор. Его
звали Феручо. И этот трактор был
маленьким, компактным, недорогим в
использовании, в применении, очень
простым. И он был очень большим
спасением для всех итальянских фермеров.
И этот человек Фиручо разбогател на
тракторах и захотел стать тоже таким
пижоном. И у него была коллекция всех
возможных видов Ferrari, которые на тот
момент времени были доступны в Италии.
Но он каждый раз жаловался, что машина
мотор классный, но коробка убогая. И он
предложил аэ Enzo Ferrari, встретившись
с ними, создать совместную марку, э, или
какую-то машину с его также именем, где
будет доработанная коробка, исходя из
его практики, механики, переборки
двигателей, который научился на Второй
мировой войне ремонтируя двигатели
танков и автомобилей. Тот, конечно, один
посмеялся и сказал: "Вы производите
трактора, вот и не лезьте в спорткары".
Это сильно оскорбило
тогда уже уважаемого мужчину по имени
Фиручо. И так мир получил новую марку
автомобилей под названием Lamborghini.
Этого человека звали Lamborghini. И
оскорбившись от такого вот ответа Enzo
Ferrari, он решил создать собственный
спортка. И да, действительно,
Lamborghini раньше выпускали трактора. И
первые Lamborghini с шилдиком этим быком
на капоте были именно у тракторов. И он
поставил нереальную задачу перед своими
конструкторами. за за огромные деньги
нанял ребят из ФИТА, а из других марок и
сказал, что мы через год должны на
автосалоне показать новую машину. И вот
их задача была показать конкурента
Ferrari. И вот представь себе, что мы
оказались в этом челлендже. Нам нужно
сказать первой Sportc. Мы ничего не
знаем про спорткары, но мы знаем, что
скорее всего, если мы сделаем машину,
которая будет иметь мощный мотор, будет
иметь, скорее всего, два пассажирских
кресла. Ну, от водительский,
пассажирская, то есть два на два места
она будет. Она будет компактная, она
будет очень зализанная и очень
агрессивно выглядеть, она будет громко
рычать и будет лёгкая, то шансы на то,
что мы эту машину сделаем успешно,
сильно выше, чем если бы, представьте
себе, мы решили строить спортка и решили
поставить туда мотор маленький, формы
квадратные, как у Гелика, огромный вес и
ещё багажник, куда холодильник можно
положить. Это уже не очень похоже на
сртка. То есть будет очень тяжело
доказать миру, что это спортка.
И вот также для меня и в жизни, то есть
для меня бизнес и успех и карьера - это
игра в вероятности. И моя задача очень
простая: не пытаться предугадать
будущее, а задать себе вопрос: какими
параметрами двигателя, коробки, выхлопа,
формы,
веса, массы, я должен как спорткар
обладать, чтобы мои шансы на успех в
жизни были максимальны. И вот я
предлагаю нам построить наш сегодняшний
диалог, эту лекцию вокруг этой метафоры,
потому что,
да, вот про это уже сказал.
Вот статистика интересная вот от
Хедхантера, компания ХТР, которая
занимается, это самый большой крупный
сайт по поиску работы в России. Они
проводили большое исследование. И
представьте себе, вот представьте себе,
только 5% респондентов сообщили, что не
работают с той профессией, о которой они
мечтали и которую они заранее
планировали. То есть вот математически
95% из вас, кто сейчас смотрит это
видео, вы вот сейчас всё, что себе
придумали, кем вы будете в жизни. Вот
вопрос: кем быть? Вы будете не им, вы
там не окажетесь. Приведу мою простой
пример. Я мастер спорта по
спортивно-бальным танцам. Я занимался
балльными танцами 13 лет. Моя последняя
партнёрша стала моей женой, с которой мы
родили пять замечательных детей погодок.
И я реально думал, что я буду тренером
по танцам. Однажды мне вопрос, кем я
буду, задала мама, когда мы ехали после
тренировки. И на вопрос я не нашёл
ответа. Она говорит: "Ну, смотри, если
ты не знаешь, как ответить, то ты сам
можешь быть тренером по танцам. Потому
что я сегодня разговаривал с твоим
тренером, и он сказал: "Вы знаете,
Оксана Владимировна, вы если из него
сделаете тренера по танцам, у него
всегда будут деньги на бутерброд с
маслом, да ещё и с икрой". Не факт, что
чёрный, но с красной точно. Мне
показалось это классной метафорой. И я
подумаю: "Ну, здорово, мне нравится
танцевать, у меня получается танцевать,
я этому уделил уже очень много лет
жизни, и я бы хотел есть мутерборд с
маслом и с икрой". И для этого, когда
все мои одноклассники и сверстники
поступали в МГУ, в школу экономики, в
Плехановку, в МФТИ и так далее, в
Бамонку, я поступил в Московский
городской педагогический университет,
который, наверное, не может похвастаться
таким же уровнем конкурса, отбора
мозговитых людей, как и вузы, которые я
перечислил. И я поступил в этот вуз. У
меня сумма баллов была небольшая по ЕГЭ.
Я написал историю на 80 баллов, русский
написал на 77, общественное знание
написал на 78, математику на 55, но
потому что написал первую, вторую часть
и ушёл. То есть у меня математика была
не нужна при поступлении, поэтому я её
как бы написал, чтобы просто аттестат
получить. И я поступил, несмотря на
такие баллы ЕГЭ, на первом месте. Я
закончил педвУЗ, и я планирую реально
быть тренером по танцам. Я даже работал
в школе 2 года учителем истории. По
закону с третьего курса ты имеешь право
работать. И, э, в Царинском районе,
возле метро Орехово, юго-восток Москвы,
я вёл историю Общагу целых 2 года в
пятых, восьмых и шестых-девятых классах.
Где я сегодня нахожусь? Сегодня я не
историк, сегодня я не бальник, сегодня я
предприниматель несколько бизнесов. Я
занимался недвижимостью в Крыму. У меня
получилось построить самую успешную
консалтивую компанию по делу продаж в
России, сам большой выручкой, обогнав
всех конкурентов. Нам удалось построить
самое крупное предматикое платное
сообщество в нашей стране, аномалия.
Сейчас только что я купил новую
медицинскую компанию, начал заниматься
активной медициной, где бальные танцы и
история, и где всё то, чем сегодня
занимаюсь. И также являюсь основателем
проекта поколения для школьников,
студентов.
Поэтому вероятность того, я считаю себя
успешным и счастливым человеком,
вероятность того, что вы, а, через 10-15
лет будете заниматься той профессией,
которую вы сегодня предполагаете, крайне
мала. И я предлагаю нам двигаться из
этой истории, что, скорее всего, вы
будете заниматься чем-то другим. Но
глупо тогда быть таким фаталистом,
думать о том, что вот жизнь сама нас
приведёт куда-то. Классно было бы всё
равно как-то себя подготовить, и мы
здесь вернёмся в метафору с автомобилем.
Поэтому вопрос звучит так: какими
параметрами я должен обладать сегодня в
15, 16,17 лет начать обладать в себе,
воспитывать, чтобы вне зависимости от
того, в какую область, профессию или
роддеятельности меня забросит жизнь или
я себя сам заброшу, я там преуспел.
И вот давай попробуем разобраться в этом
вопросе. То есть, да, вот круто,
конечно, что-то себе планировать, а, но
на самом деле там нам нужно собрать
такую формулу с идеальными ингредиентами
и с крутой темы, правильного партнёра,
сильной команды, растущего тренда,
каких-то своих компетенций и навыков. И
вот я я для вас подготовил несколько
идей. Они достаточно все такие очень
прагматичные, а, очень точные, которые
могут кратно повысить ваши шансы на
успех в жизни. Неважно, чем бы вы
занимались, даже если вы решите стать
тренером по бальным танцам, вы решите
стать историком профессиональным или вы
решить решите стать предпринимателем.
Итак, первая идея, что
был такой World Economics Forum, и он
приводит такой исследование, что
представьте себе, 65% из вас, кто сейчас
слушает наш эфир или смотрит эту лекцию
в интернете, вы будете работать в тех
отраслях, в тех бизнесах, на тех
профессиях, которые сегодня ещё даже не
существуют. Ещё даже человечество не
изобрело эти профессии, в которых вы
будете работать и в которых вы
преуспеете. в которых вы станете
успешными и заработа свои капиталы и
свои деньги, и станете очень
стоятельными людьми. Поэтому какой смысл
себе это прогнозировать, если ещё даже
это люди не изобрели, но это случится,
потому что мир очень быстро развивается.
А что будет определять идея вторая, ваш
доход? А ещё там 30 лет назад, 50 лет
назад в Советском Союзе, в Новой России,
там в девяностых годах, двухтысячных
наших родителей с вами там, да,
предопределение было это выбор
профессии. То есть, если ты хорошо
выбрал профессию, ты занимался ей, там
много лет, учился, готовился, потом 20
лет отпахал на на этой профессии, ты,
скорее всего, преуспеешь. Больше этот
этот момент не работает. Поэтому сегодня
новая способность - это не стать лучшим
архитектором или лучшим юристом или
лучшим доктором. Сегодня самый главный
навык, который нужно в себе воспитывать
- это быть готовым постоянно
переучиваться.
признать тот факт, что действительно
всё, что вы сегодня знаете, устарет
очень быстро. И мне кажется, что
главное, на что опирается сегодня мой
успех в жизни - это то, что я постоянно
учусь. Вот из последнего прямо вот
последние 2 месяца я прохожу очень
большое глубокое обучение по работе с
чатом GPT. Я им пользуюсь уже больше 2
лет, но я скажу так, что CH GPT для меня
открылся по ном. Я вообще его не
понимал, абсолютно не понимал, как им
пользоваться, какие из него возможности
можно доставать. И вот, да, вот сейчас
мне 33 года, вроде бы успешный человек,
209 там 80.000 подписчиков в Телеграме,
500.000 в Ютубе, предприниматель, личный
бренд, бизнесы, деньги, успех, слава,
надо идти учиться дальше. Поэтому мне
кажется, что способность быстро
переучиваться - это определяющий навык
будущего в следующие 15-20 лет. Гораздо
важнее точного выбора профессии. и
готовность. А, а что, опять всё сначала
начинать? Да, опять сначала. И так будет
очень много раз в вашей жизни. Третья
идея. Аэ для людей, которым сегодня 15,
16, 18 лет, вам критически важно начать
себя развивать по т-образной формуле.
Что означает т-образная формула? Это
значит, что вы должны максимально широко
разбираться в огромном количестве тем,
поверхностно, но иметь очень широкий
кругозор, как можно раньше, и очень
глубоко, как буква Т, проваливаться и
быть гиперэкспертом в какой-то одной
теме. Приведу пример, в чём вы должны
точно уже понимать. Вы должны понимать в
маркетинге, вы должны понимать в найме,
в продажах, в истории, в геополитике, в
географии, а где-то базово в медицине
долголетии, в устройстве государства, в
юриспруденции, в бухгалтерии,
в экономике. Вы во всём этом должны
понимать, в социологии должны понимать.
И, допустим, вы очень хорошо будете
понимать, например, искусственный
интеллект или очень хорошо будете
понимать продакшн, режиссуру. а, съёмки
видео, фильмов, э, или контента, или вы
очень глубоко будете понимать
строительство очень хорошо или,
допустим, стоматологию.
Вот именно такая Т-образная формула
сегодня является ключом к успеху к
будущей жизни. Плохо, когда вы во всём
разбираетесь, но нету одной узкой,
глубокой темы, в которой вы гиперэсперт.
И плохо, если вы разбираетесь в чём-то
одном очень глубоко, но не понимаете,
какой строн мир. Я могу про себя смело
сказать, что я понимаю про спорт
благодаря бальным танцам.
Я понимаю про историю и про геополитику
благодаря истории. То, что я закончил
исторический факультет. Я учитель
истории. Это нам дало много знаний о
мире и географических знаний, и
исторических, и управленческих. Я
понимаю в менеджменте, я понимаю в
построении компании, я понимаю базовый
госаппарат, госустройство и экономику,
но я очень глубоко понимаю тему продаж.
Это первая тема, в которой я, ну, могу
смело сказать, что я, наверное, точно
вхожу в 1% людей в России, понимающих
эту тему лучше, чем остальные 99%.
У меня есть и другие темы, кстати, к
тридцатм годам. И я считаю, что у меня
уже не т-образно, у меня скорее
перевёрнутая ше-образная история. Я, мне
кажется, неплохо разобрался в вопросе
создания контента. И у нас получается
генерить вирусный контент. Я точно могу
сказать, что я понимаю в нём больше, чем
там 99% населения страны.
В публичных выступлениях я очень много
учился тому, как выступать, как говорить
на публику, держать зал, работать с ним,
ходил на лекции, ходил на чужие
мастер-классы, анализировал, какие
инструменты применяют мои коллеги по
цеху, чтобы быть успешными ораторами.
Поэтому вот подумайте, какие вообще вот
я бы на вашем месте сейчас себе такое
задание бы прямо взял. Я бы попробовал
можно сжептишкой, можно с гигачатом,
можно с чатом GPT создать себе список.
Попробуй задать мне там, не знаю, как
можно больше уточняющих вопросов,
просканировать меня на предмет моего в
целом кругозора и создать мне личный
личный конкретный план. А для того,
чтобы я каждый месяц познавал новую
область жизни. По чуть-чуть везде по
чуть-чуть надо понимать. Это очень
важно, чтобы насмотреность была хорошая.
и уже сегодня подумать о том, какая тема
вас особенно привлекает, особенно
интересна, которой вы можете очень долго
заниматься и в неё глубоко погрузиться.
Например, я играю в Доту. Мне нравится
играть Доту. Сразу для всех, кто играет
Доту, скажу, что у меня 3.000м. Я играю
на четвёртой, пятой позиции, саппорт.
Даже последние 2 года мы проводим первый
в России турнир по доте для
предпринимателей. Год назад был первый
пробный, в этом году уже более
масштабный мы провели. И даже компания
WF признала наш турнир. И в Доте, прямо
внутри игры, в сетке турниров даже был
из неофициальных турниров наш Boss
Battle. Можете посмотреть в интернете
Boss Battle 2025. Это был турнир для
предпринимателей по Доте. Чему меня
научила Дота? Я в целом весьма неплохо
понимаю Доту, понимаю логику игры. Да,
может, и не суперэкспертный там, чтобы
играть на огромный рейтинг, но базово
гейм-дизайн как игры, как она построена,
как устроено удержание внимания, как
построена рейтинговая система, как
построены патчи, апдейты, как построена
игра вокруг, эти всякие батлпасы,
по сути, это же это геймдизайн. Мне это
очень интересно. И представьте себе
предпринимателя, который возьмёт нишу
хорики, ресторанное обслуживание и в ней
сделает успешно геймдизайн. Это будут
очень успешный предприниматель. Я такого
знаю. Этим предпринимателем является мой
близкий товарищ Андрей, который построил
в Москве одну из самых успешных
заведений кальянных. Вы её, наверное,
слышали про неё. Кальян называется
Timeless. Их выручка очень большая. Это
многомиллиардная компания, успешная
компания. И это самая, наверное, для
меня сегодня финансово и при по прибыли
успешная сеть заведений с кальянами в
нашей стране. Но важно другое. Когда я
попросил его провести мне экскурсию, он
показал мне разработанную IT-платформу,
собственную он сам разработал
IT-платформу. Он тоже играет Доту. Мы с
ним играли в Доту тоже много раз вместе.
Он суперфанат гейм-дизайна. И он для
своих кальянщиков, для официантов, для
Бориста сделал приложение, в котором они
выполняют квесты, потому что его
сотрудники, в основном это молодёжь. И
он им сделал не просто тупую мотивацию,
а клад процент продаж. У них реально там
квесты, доминатор, там продать самый
дорогой кальян дня, сделать самый
большой чек, и они, выполняя квесты,
зарабатывают свои очки, рейтинги и таким
образом поднимают себе зарплату. И вот
он взял геймдизайн, в котором он круто
разобрался. По факту Timeless - это не
это не ресторан и не кальянная. Это
гейм-платформа, которая наложена на
обычный общепит в переменной упаковке,
ещё при этом с эстетикой классной и вот
с нишей кальянов.
Вот вам пример. И очень успешно сейчас
открыл первое колено в Дубае. Они все
прибыльные, успешно отбиваются. Это вот
вам примерно подумать, куда двигаться
вам, развиваться в чём. Дальше, а мне
кажется, что самая дорогая валюта дальше
будет это валюта внимания. В силу того,
что
количество контента, маркетинга,
диджитализации будет только возрастать в
силу развития IT-технологий,
а нас будет всё больше атаковать
инфошум, IT-шум со стороны.
И поэтому тот, кто умеет круто
захватывать внимание, будет получать
трафик, равно будет получать продажи,
равно будет получать деньги. И мне
кажется, что уже сегодня вы должны
начать учиться, управлять и захватывать
вниманием. Какое я здесь для вас
предлагаю сделать упражнение? Я
предлагаю вам, если вы до сих пор этого
не сделали, сделать это, созвести свой
Telegram-канал,
подписать на него всех своих друзей,
всех своих близких, просто физически
ходить, чтобы вы первые 150.000
подписчиков набрали. Просто людям
предлагаю подписаться, чтобы они стали
вашими зрителями. Вы нашли свою тему для
блога и начали писать посты. Я вот,
например, как человек, который
производит контент в больших
количествах, э восхищаюсь абсолютно
мистером Бистом. Знаете, наверняка
такого ютубера. Это самый известный,
самый успешный ютубер, YouTube-блогер в
мире. И пока меня однажды очень сильно
зацепила одна мысль, что на ролике, где
мистер Бист путешествует всеми
возможными авиакомпаниями мира и
сравнивает их между собой, было что-то
там 15 или 20 млн просмотров. А на
ролике, где Мистер Бист рассказывает,
как он построил свою империю, было всего
200.000 просмотров. Это такой вопрос,
что людям интересно. Я такой, я помню
этот видео про самолёты, но я не смотрел
видео интервью, где он рассказывает, а
он реально дал кучу интервью, в которых
он сам просто вот в открыту рассказал
весь свой путь, как он это сделал, как
они работают, как они подходят к
контенту. И он рассказал базовый принцип
успеха в контенте. И я просто вот ничего
лучшего пока не слышал. Он говорит:
"Если ты хочешь стать успешным в Ютубе,
тебе нужно выложить 100 роликов, тебе
нужно снять 100 видео. И, скорее всего,
первое видео будет полное, второе будет
тоже ужасное, третье будет ужасное, но
тебе должно быть плевать, что они не
залетают. Ты должен перед собой
поставить только одну задачу, чтобы твоё
каждое следующее видео было хоть чуточку
чем-то, но лучше предыдущего. Первой
снимаешь как-то. Во втором ты уже
продумал сценарий. В третьем ты
поработал ещё и с заголовком. В
четвёртом ты сделал себе классный свет.
В пятом добавил музыку на фоне. В шестом
ты сделал классный монтаж. В седьмом
добавил классные хуки в начале, в
середине и в конце, чтобы тебя было
интересно слушать. В восьмом ты добавил
гостя. В девятом ты добавил какую-нибудь
рекламу там, да, чтобы уже как-то
пытаться окупиться. В двенадцатом
добавил какой-то фирмный стиль себе
одежду прикрутил. В тринадцатом ты
добавил интригу и нарезки и так далее. И
говорит: "Если ты будешь 100 роликов
выкладывать и у тебя будет челлендж 100
роликов, где каждый должен быть чуточку
лучше предыдущего с сохранием всех
прошлых улучшений итераций, ты рано или
поздно упрёшься в то, что у тебя будут
крутые просмотры и охваты". Мы взяли эту
стратегию с моим сыном. Моему сыну 7
лет. Он обожает рыбалку. Просто
перекрытый фанат рыбалки. Однажды
порыбачил на Мальдивах со мной. И вот с
тех пор он рыбачит и рыбачит. Вот.
Обожает рыбалку больше всего в мире. И
его цепляет то, что у меня есть
серебряная кнопка Ютуба. У меня 500.000
в Ютубе. Серебряная кнопка 100.000
даётся.
И он говорит: "Пап, я теб сделаю, тоже
хочу себе серебряную кнопку". И он
говорит: "Пап, я хочу свой YouTube канал
про рыбалку". Ну, я поддержал его хобби.
И вот мы с ним уже почти год снимаем
ролики про рыбалку. Он ходит на рыбалку,
может даже его видели. Наберите в Ютубе
Елисей Гребенк рыбалка. И он набрал за
полгода 10.000 подписчиков первых. У неё
есть шорсы на миллион. Всё, что мы
делаем с ним каждый раз, мы с ним
думаем, как следующий ролик сделать
чуточку лучше предыдущего. Добавить
интриги, добавить зацепы. Первый ролик -
это был просто тихий ужас. Он терялся на
камеру, нёс какую-то чепуху, волновался,
это было ужасно. Но сегодня мой сын уже
свои ролики сам просит меня с ним сесть,
пересмотреть, и он сидит: "Ага, вот
здесь можно так было лучше сделать, вот
можно так докрутить". Поэтому подпишите
всех своих друзей на Telegram-канал и
начните что-то там рассказывать.
Выберите какую-то тему, как вы идёте к
цели по спорту. Поставьте себе цель
поступить в вуз, как вы это делаете.
Поставьте себе цель, э, разобраться там
в чём-то. И пишите свой путь успеха и
смотрите на вовлечение. Охваты,
подписки, отписки, репосты, лайки. Не
потому, что просто не ваши друзья, а
смотрите, чтобы эти метрики начали
расти. И вы за счёт этого сегодня
бесплатно уже эту экспертизу получите. Я
думаю, что если вы окажетесь в возрасте
25-30 лет с этой этим навыком, вы будете
гиперконкурентны.
Следующее. Главный навык поколения,
которым сегодня 1525 - это уметь
комбинировать разные темы. например,
айтишку и медицину, спорт и развлечение,
образование с контентом. Вот что мы
сделали. Мы добавили просто было раньше,
раньше было скучное образование
академичное. NBA давали людям про
бизнес. Мы взяли, сделали из него
немножко шоу, разборы, классный классный
вайб, хорошая лексика. Я выхожу не в
костюме с галстуком, выхожу в оверсайзе,
где-то иногда могу себе позволить
поматериться, где-то устраиваю реально
прямо такое, ну, разгон эмоциональный
сильный, до слёз довожу людей, там сам
плачу. И это сделало бизнесобразование
нескучно. И поэтому нам удалось на стыке
шоу и бизнесобразования сотворить свою
медиаимперию.
То же самое с вами. Вы должны подумать,
какие сегодня уже вы можете вещи
скомбинировать. Ваш блог скомбинирует с
вашим спортом.
ваш спорт скомбинировать с какой-нибудь
айтишкой, попытаться ваш нетворкинг,
бизнес-клуб какой-нибудь создать, там
клуб по интересам, соединить его с
искусством, с творчеством. И вот стык
двух параллелей. И вот это это есть на
самом деле предпринимательство. Вообще
мегатренд, что все должны быть немножко
предпринимателями, даже если вы не
рождённый предниматель, хотя я считаю,
что это всё-таки рождённое качество,
вот щепотку преднимательства каждому
нужно в себе воспитать. Это способно
взять чуть-чуть науки, чуть-чуть
искусства, чуть-чуть комьюнити,
чуть-чуть IT, чуть-чуть медицины и на
выходе сделать мегапродукт, который
будет успешным, сделат вас богатым,
стояным человеком. Дальше. Рынок труда
всё сильнее становится и станет ещё
сильнее рынком портфолио, а не рынком
одной работы. Это большой мегатренд. Все
компании, которые я знаю, перестали
смотреть на дипломы. диплом не смотрит
на собеседование, смотрит, что ты
сделал, какие у тебя успешные проекты в
портфолио. И чем они более
широкообразные,
многогранные, многовероятные, тем более
ты интересный человек. Я себе охотне
возьму топ-менеджера, который в свои там
25 лет уже поработал и в IT, и в
недвижимости, и в маркетинге, и в
продаже им поработал, и какой-нибудь
социальный проект благотворительный
построил, чем того, кто просто 20 лет
долбил только программирование.
Кругозор - это всё сегодня. Поэтому вам
нужно перестать думать про одну
профессию, начать думать про то, какой
вы уже сегодня опытно работали. Перед
вами только что выступала Ева. Это наша
участница поколения. Ева уже поработала
ассистентом моей жены. Она работала и
работала ассистентом моих ассистентов.
Она помогала нанимать в Мы сейчас
снимали фильм, и нужно было за 2 дня
найти группу цыган, близнецов, карликов,
лысых, старых мужиков-актёров для одного
фильма, который мы придумали,
режиссёров, и она всё это смогла найти.
А на следующий день она приехала ко мне
домой, нашла подрядчиков и украшала мой
дом с там со мной, с моей женой и
нянями, ёлку и украшала огромный наш дом
новогодними украшениями. То есть
насколько у неё уже богатый кругозор в
её там 18-17 лет. Она большая младица, у
неё огромные шансы перед её сверстниками
уже преуспеть жизнь.
Следующий большой мегатренд. Уже сегодня
недавно вышло исследование в России
разрыв между линейным специалистом и
топ-менеджером компании пример в
зарплате примерно 30-50 раз. Вдумайтесь
это, это сумасшедшая цифра.
Разница в зарплате 30-50 раз. Но это не
всё. Я поднял статистику. Стало
интересно, что на Западе происходит.
Западный капитализм чуть раньше начался,
чем у нас. Поэтому у них они чуть вперёд
продвинулись в этом плане. В Европе
соотношение линейного сотрудника к
топ-менеджменту 1 к 130 зарплат. В
Америке 1 к 270, а по некоторым отрас 1
к 500. То есть линейные сотрудник
компании получает в 500 раз меньше, чем
топ-менеджер.
Я думаю, что разрыв будет только расти.
И действительно сегодня в России мы
видим огромный дефицит сильных
менеджеров, сильных управленческих
кадров. Что это значит? Это значит, что
страшно бизнесу. предприятиям не хватает
людей, не которые просто делают функции
процессы, а людей, которые умеют брать
область и доводить её до результата.
Целую область доводить до результата.
Следующая идея. А данных в мире будет
становиться только всё больше и больше.
И в результате победят только те, а, кто
умеют их правильно структурировать,
архивировать и с ними работать.
закончилась конкуренция на уровне того,
сколько ты знаешь и помнишь в своей
голове. Это больше не имеет никакого
смысла. Нет никаких шансов запомнить всё
это, то, что помнят машины, люди, ну вот
инструменты, айтишки,
иишки и неронки. Поэтому главный навык
не помнить, а вот эта вот
изобретательность, креативность,
нестандартный подход, алгорит, понимание
алгоритмов, как они взаимодействуют с
тобой, и из них доставать нужны тебе
данные быстро. И вот здесь мы видим этот
ваш широкий кругозор, наложенный на ваши
способности изучать эти все вот
современные IT-платформы глубоко и будут
давать вам гиперконкурентное
преимущество. Не просто как в поисковик
в Яндексегре забить запрос птишку. Тут
много мозгов не надо. Вот из последнего,
что, допустим, я понял, вот реально
пример. Я сейчас создавал с помощью чата
GPT новую бизнес-модель для медицинской
компании. Я скормил его много файлов. И
один из файлов были транскрибации
разговоров с отделами. Я ему рассказал,
как выглядят мои подразделения компании,
попросил его составить мне списки
вопросов, а для того, чтобы я мог пойти
и сделать им интервью.
Дальше я пошёл к этим подразделениям,
сел с диктофоном и задавал им эти там
вопросы и и записались там четыре у меня
было, по-моему, полуторачасовых
интервью. Это были врачи, кураторы,
диспетчерская медсёстры, с которыми
пообщался. Я эти файлы скармливаю тебя
от уже пяти.
Я ему говорю: "Скажи, пожалуйста, что ты
понял?" И он мне даёт реально крутые
выводы из этого файла. Реально крутые
выводы.
Но я решил проверить. Я говорю: "Скажи,
пожалуйста, а сколько знаков, символов в
этом документе?" Он говорит: "Я не
знаю". Я такой: "Так, ты же его
прочитал". Он говорит: "Ну, примерно
примерно 302 350.000".
Я говорю: "Как так? Ты не можешь
посчитать? Посчитай мне точную цифру".
Он говорит: "Я не могу почитать точно
цифру, потому что файл doc x читается не
полностью. У меня нет способности
прочитать файл doc x полностью".
Я говорю: "А как это сделать? Файл". Я
ему закармливаю файл. Это же самой
транскрибация. Говорю: "Посчитай". Он
пишет: "83.745 символов". Я ему пишу:
"Ты врёшь не столько". Он говорит: "Я
пересчитал там ещё раз 83.000 там 475
символов".
И я вот таким способом, вот эта
маленькая деталь, её не было даже в
обучении по нейронгам, который проходил
от крутого университета
выходцев из бера гигачат.
И, ну, и этот навык у меня теперь, я
теперь знаю, что если оскармливаем ему
файлы, то он их читает не по диагонали,
а целиком, и любые микродетали из этого
проекта не пропадут, и он их точно
возьмёт во внимание.
А, и ещё один большой мегатренд. А, в
России большая демографическая яма.
надвигается и, ну, уже посчитано, это
уже неизбежно, что через 10 лет в России
примерно 40% населения страны будет
старше 50 лет. О чём это говорит? Что
будут расширяться ниши бизнес-модели,
которые обслуживают людей с серебряного
и золотого века. Всё, что связано с
долголетием: медицина, фитнес-услуги,
путешествие для людей 50 п, забота о
здоровье, дома престарелых, уборка,
квартиры с инфраструктурой, девелопмент
с инфраструктурой для этих людей. Всё
будет развиваться, расти. Поэтому, если
вы задумываетесь в сторону
предпринимательства, то я на вашем месте
бы уже сегодня начал бы активно изучать,
как живут, чем живут люди 50 +, какие у
них сегодня есть проблемы, потому что
для меня бизнес - это решение чужой
проблемы за деньги. И если вы хотите
преуспеть в бизнесе, то высока
вероятность, что вы к 25 годам, если вы
откроете не бизнес для молодёжи, а
бизнес для людей 50 п, какую-либо
индустрию, нишу, в идеале это будет
микс, там, да, айтишка с медициной, там
стоматологией, с гемификацией.
И таким образом эти люди будут вашими
клиентами, и вы станете состоятельными
людьми. Вот такие первые выводы, которые
я хотел донести. У меня, к сожалению,
сегодня немного времени. Хотелось как
так вот максимально плотненько выдать
вам контент. А напишите, пожалуйста, в
чате, что из того, что я рассказал, вам
особенно сильно зацепило, зашло,
вдохновило. И от себя хочется сказать,
могли бы вывести QR-код, да, расскажу
про проект поколения. В общем, то, что
вот я сейчас вам рассказал, представьте
себе, мы рассказали это бесплатно. И
когда я был преподавателем истории в
школе, мне очень нравилось ребятам на
переменах рассказывать и обсуждать тему
успеха, будущего, каких-то идей, чем они
хотят заниматься, их поддерживать,
наставлять. Я себе пообещал, что когда
стану постарше и будут возможности
финансовые и временные, то я точно
возьму себе группу из ребят подростков и
буду бесплатно их наставником 10 лет. Я
так сделал год назад. Сейчас у меня есть
прекрасная группа из тридцати пти ребят,
которые сегодня являются моими
учениками. И я пообещал им, что я
бесплатно буду их наставлять и буду их
старшим товарищем, пока им не станет 25
лет. Моя большая миссия, идея в этом
том, чтобы ребята в свои 25 лет поняли
про мир, жизнь и бизнес. То, что я понял
только в 3540. И я бы очень хотел, чтобы
вы, наше следующее поколение нашей
страны, на 10 лет преуспели, получили 10
лет преимущества в опыте, в передаче
жизни опыта перед моим поколением.
И вот такой проект я создал. А ко мне
посдились мои партнёры Юли, Артур, и они
тоже взяли группы. И сегодня у нас,
представьте себе, спустя год, благодаря
нашей прекрасной команде и Алине,
директору проекта, мы собрали уже 50
групп и полтыся подростков, которых
наставляют самые сильные предприниматели
нашей страны и топ-менеджеры. И у вас
есть возможность с такого уровня людьми
бесплатно взаимодействовать. Но я не
знаю, какие возможности просто ещё лучше
можно придумать для того, чтобы стать
успешным в жизни. Нам абсолютно плевать,
кто ваши родители. Нам плевать, сколько
у вас денег. Нам важно, кто вы, что у
вас вот здесь и что у вас вот здесь и
куда вы стремитесь и кем вы хотите
стать. И мы не смотрим на блад,
на связи, мы смотрим только на то, какой
вы человек. Поэтому, если вы, послушав
эту лекцию и наш сегодняшний эфир,
почувствовали, что вы хотите преуспеть,
вы хотите быстрее, чем ваши сверстники,
развиться, встать на ноги, стать
успешными, состояными, не обязательно
бизнес или карьера или учёные в любой
сфере, просто стать успешным, не быть
посредственными, то я вам настоятельно
рекомендую стать участником нашего
проекта поколения. Мы очень хотим, чтобы
за ближайшие,
э, 2 года, 2-3 года, у нас было 1.000
групп и 30.000
ребят молодых мы объединили под нашим
флагом и дали наставников. Повторюсь,
это благотвительный проект. Вы ничего за
это платить не будете. Но единственное,
что вы делаете для того, чтобы
участвовать в этом, вы даёте клятву, что
если вы в эту группу входите и в ней
работаете 10 лет, то когда вы встанете
на ноги и вам уже будет 25-30 лет, вы
тоже должны будете взять группу из
тридцати подростков и тоже отвести её 10
лет. Это будет ваша плата дальше
следующему поколению. И поэтому проект
называется поколение, что моё поколение
передаёт вам, ваше поколение передаст
дальше следующем. И даст Бог, я и вы в
старости увидим пятое, шестое поколение
людей, которые будут петь нашими с вами
голосами, как мы с вами строили нашу
страну и нашу с вами жизнь, наши с вами
судьбы. Так что очень рекомендую вам
подписаться на наш Telegram-канал
Поколения, прямо можно его вбить. Наша
некоммерческая организация, а и все
новые анонсы наставников, групп мы
публикуем именно там. Там всегда есть
возможность пройти отбор. То есть мы
говорим: "Вот новая группа, описание
наставника. Оставляйте заявку, проходите
тест испытания, даже собеседование. Если
вам всё, ну, вам всё нравится, нам всё
нравится, то у вас появляется шанс найти
себе своего наставника". Сразу скажу,
что проект не только московский, и он
работает по всей стране, не только
здесь. Поэтому вы може у нас уже есть
группы и в Вологде, а, и в Сибири,
Дальнем Востоке, даже есть
онлайн-группы. Так что у каждого должен
быть шанс на то, чтобы найти себе
старшего товарища. И поверьте, у нас
нету недостатка в этих людях. У нас
большой недостаток в заряженных молодых
ребятах, которые хотят построить
успешную жизнь и которые жадно хотят
впитывать наши знания, наш опыт, которым
мы с вами готовы просто так делиться,
чтобы мы с вами построили новую классную
Россию.
У меня всё. Спасибо, что были с нами.
Спасибо, что послушали, посмотрели наш
эфир, наш онлайнмарафон. Подписывайся на
наш канал. Telegram поколения. И у нас,
хочу сказать, что сейчас открыта запись
к новым пяти наставникам. Вся информация
по ним также будет там.